Cuál es el reto que tiene en materia de
seguridad tanto el gobierno de Venezuela
como el gobierno colombiano para mitigar
toda y toda esta inseguridad y que
realmente hablando del lado comercial
que los más importantes también el día
de hoy los empresarios se sientan
seguros que no los cobren nos vacunas eh
Como para digamos extorsiones no que
pueden hacer estas bandas criminales ya
que no pueden hacerlo con los ciudadanos
si efectivamente otro reto es el de la
seguridad la ausencia del estado en el
territorio y la ausencia en las
fronteras al final de cuentas alimenta
la creación de nuevos mercados ilícitos
de organizaciones criminales Y eso lo
hemos visto a lo largo de estos siete
años en donde están fortalecido tanto
grupos guerrilleros grupos disidentes
del proceso de paz e incluso bandas de
narcotraficantes en ese sentido lo que
se busca es que Efectivamente es
Venezuela por un lado tiene que arreglar
el asunto de seguridad de internet es
decir tiene que al final de cuentas
asentar de nuevos autoridad sobre el
territorio y no compartir esa soberanía
con otros digamos grupos criminales eso
es un asunto que tiene Caracas pendiente
y Que obviamente genera mucha
desconfianza en Colombia pero también
Colombia tiene que hacer el esfuerzo de
restablecer pronto lo que se llama la
comisión binacional en ese sentido
sentarse a hablar sinceramente sobre los
temas en cuanto a la seguridad y cuáles
son Cuáles los roles de cada uno de los
países en términos de la frontera y
cuáles son las funciones que cada uno
debe cumplir en ese en ese mar es algo
que debe hacerse pronto para que
efectivamente no solamente en términos
del comercio sino en términos de la
seguridad obviamente las comunidades se
sientan mucho más seguras Manuel y no
dejamos de un lado por supuesto la
migración venezolana que va a pasar con
esta nueva reapertura de la frontera se
va a incrementar digamos esta migración
ese flujo de ciudades venezolanos que
salen todos los días para buscar una
mejor ya con rumbo a Estados Unidos
ahí esto tatió sobre que esta reapertura
económica
limite un poco la migración sin embargo
las migraciones tienen siempre varios
factores desde factores F esencialmente
económicos como esencialmente políticos
en ese sentido La idea es que la
reapertura trate de limitar los las
causas económicas de la migración
Obviamente
el tema político siempre tiene una
afectación muy importante en términos
del comercio y de la economía y
obviamente como una frontera vivió al
final de cuentas no vas a reducirse el
flujo migratorio que ha venido
históricamente pasando digamos en estos
digamos en este territorio en ese
sentido también hay que tener en cuenta
que la migración venezolana
no han existido de alguna forma
declaraciones por parte de los dos
gobiernos en respecto a cómo van a
sostener
las instituciones migratorias es decir
si Colombia va a mantener el digamos el
lo que tiene que estatuto temporal de
migración y efectivamente que va a ser
Venezuela para tratar de generar una
migración de retorno que de alguna forma
mejore las relaciones en términos de los
flujos migratorios entre ambos países